well ESPN in the NFL cheered the
supposed courage of former San Francisco
49ers quarterback Colin Kaepernick who
stuck his job for failing to stand for
the national anthem it turns out the
viewers were less sanguine according to
a new poll from JD power the number one
reason fans decided not to watch the NFL
last year was the national anthem
protests which ended up spreading to
several teams and multiple players fully
26 percent of people who said they
watched less NFL content last year said
they did so because of the national
anthem anthem crap another 24 percent
said the domestic violence and delay of
game penalties kept them away the second
major poll to confirm the leftist
politics drove Americans from watching
football in October 2016 56 percent of
fans said they believed the ratings were
down because of the national anthem
protest they were right which means the
West's unwavering desire to infuse
politics even into even the most
apolitical content comes with a cost
alienation of an audience that disagrees
while polls show that the bulk of
Americans despise the national anthem
protest those statistics polarized by
race 63 percent of white Americans
dislike the protests a plurality of
Hispanics disapproved forty five percent
to thirty six percent but fully 74
percent of black Americans liked the
protests overall 54% of Americans
opposed the protests with just 38
percent of proving that racial
polarization the grip the nation over
the last several years thanks to the
rise of black lives matter and President
Obama's decision to humor racially
divisive politics it didn't leave
football untouched and the leftist at
the sports networks in an attempt to
mirror their political idols of the
Democratic Party celebrated as their own
industry and vibe from the
intersectional bottle the cost ratings
mixing politics into sport has withdrawn
an essential part of our civic culture
from the realm of the universal and
that's going to have larger
ramifications than merely a drop in NFL
ratings i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
some days there is so much news that it
is impossible to get through everything
that is why I'm now going to speak it
three times by normal speed because
there was just so much news that
happened yesterday I was on the hill I
was testifying about censorship on
college campuses we'll play some tape of
that because it was a lot of fun I
testified Adam Carolla testified and it
was the unique experience that I want to
tell you about ahead some thoughts on it
also in in bigger news
Anthony Sierra Moochie who is the the
soon-to-be White House chief of staff if
the rumors are true lost his mind in an
interview with The New Yorker and I have
to tell you about it because at this
point I am just in it for the amusement
at this point you know I'd like to see
good policy be made but if I can't get
good policy then again well want to be
entertained Anthony scaramouche you make
that happen for me so I will be telling
you about that and speaking of policy if
it's not getting past skinny repealed
Len towns of flamin defeat after John
McCain throttles it with his with his
old hand and so will tell you about what
happened there and why actually isn't
the worst thing in the world for
Republicans this happens I'll give you
actually a bit of good news today I know
shocking it's me but I will it'll still
happen but before I get to any of that
if that's not line if I don't know it
before I get to any of that I first want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
ProFlowers so I was recently sent a
bouquet of farmstand flowers from Pro
flowers for my wife and what's super
cool about farmstand flowers is that
they change what's in the bouquet
depending on what's seasonal so when you
get a new farm stand flowers bouquet it
may be different than the last one you
got so it's always a bit of a surprise
it's always fresh it's always
high-quality and when you send pro
flowers farmstand flowers you get 20%
off this collection or any other of
their unique exclusive bouquets of
twenty nine dollars or more
proflowers.com makes choosing the right
surprise bouquet simple and quick
they're guaranteed to stay fresh for at
least seven days or your money back I've
gotten many bouquets over the years from
proflowers.com just going on the road I
like to send my wife flowers and these
things stay fresh forever I mean they
stay fresh a lot longer than the flowers
that you would get from the local market
which starts with will almost
immediately upon you arriving home
proflowers.com has a guarantee that they
will stay fresh for at least seven days
or your money back you get to pick the
exact date that the surprise will arrive
and the
the flowers themselves are just
beautiful they're all high-quality get
to get 20% off your farm stand flowers
or any other bootcamp 29 bucks or more
go to proflowers.com and use my code
been show at checkout that's ProFlowers
calm and use the code been show been
show at checkout that lets the minute we
say you also get that 20 percent
discount off of any bouquet of twenty
nine dollars or more farm stand flowers
will be my choice is just fantastic
stuff my wife really appreciated it
which is good too that cuts are off
enough that i have to keep her happy
somehow so go who could propel ours calm
and use the promo code then show at
checkout to get that twenty percent
discount ok so I don't even know where
to begin because there's so much
entertaining things there's so many
things so all the things so I'm actually
going to start in a place where I think
the media is not covering things and
that is there's a story that came out
yesterday it really does throw a crimp
into the style of the Democrats when it
comes to this Russian narrative I talked
about this little bit yesterday I wanted
to give you the update so it since
Hillary's watching what's has been
saying that Russia wanted Trump to win
and that's why Trump won that there was
some sort of collusion so far there's no
evidence of actual collusion there's
willingness to collude from Don junior
to these Russian lawyers but there's no
actual evidence of collusion and there's
no evidence that the Russians actually
wanted Trump to win as opposed to just
screwing with our election cycle well
last weekend a little notice move the
Senate Judiciary Committee called the
guy named Bill browner to testify
routers a financier who's been targeted
by the Vladimir Putin regime and he
testified according to the Weekly
Standard that fusion GPS which is a
Democrat link to Oppo research firm
arranged the meeting between tunnels
from junior and Russian lawyers and
furthermore Browder stated that these
Russian lawyers had hired fusion GPS to
conduct a smear campaign against him and
the reports are that fusion gps has
contracted the russians and maybe they
were hired by the russians in order to
come up with the hands head trump
dossier the reason this is important is
because it does again destroy the
democrat narrative that the reason Trump
won is because the Russians wanted him
to win but it looks like more is that
the Russians were screwing with all
sides they were there working on the the
Trump dossier at the same time they were
playing the other side of the aisle with
Trump which means that that's a pretty
large con founding factor when you say
did the Russians hurt Trump or do they
help Trump well it's possible that the
Russians did both and so I think that
hurts the Democrat
narrative in a pretty significant way
which is one of the reasons why Democrat
media does not want to report all of
that okay but what they do here's the
thing Trump could be saying all that
right term could be focusing on that you
could also have been focusing in on
health care the health care went down to
flaming defeat yesterday and I'll talk
about that before I get to scare mochi I
always save dessert for last
scaramouche is the dessert scaramouche
is fantastic but last night very late at
night I'm on a plane because I'm an
idiot and I went to Dulles Airport
instead of Reagan National Airport to
get home from Washington DC so I had to
hop a later flight and on the flight
home I'm sitting there there's nothing
worse than being in the middle seat
watching watching CNN cover a late night
healthcare vote it's just a bunch of old
people milling around on the floor and
you don't know what's going on but
everyone's trying to read body language
and the what what was up for a vote was
what they called skinny repeal as I
mentioned yesterday skinny repeal was
basically they get rid of the individual
mandate for a small amount of time they
get rid of the employer mandate for a
certain amount of time but they really
repeal are the penalties for the
individual mandate and the employer
mandate in reality the medical device
tax was suspended for only three years
Philip Ryan had a good break down at the
Washington Examiner and the employer
mandate penalties would go to zero at
first but would come back actually by
2025 taken together according to health
policy analyst Chris Jacobs the bill
would keep 411 out of Obama cares 419
sections of legislative texts intact so
it was not a repeal that's why they
called it a skinny repeal the biggest
problem with skinny repeal and the
reason a lot of people opposed it is
because it left all of the Obamacare
regulations in place but it got rid of
the funding mechanism for the Obamacare
regulations which means all the prices
are going to immediately begin rising
very very quickly in the individual
market it also didn't make any sort of
Medicaid restructuring so a lot of
people would presumably be thrown onto
Medicaid across the government would
then absorb so it's not it's not a good
be able though I mean the skinny repeal
is not an ability they fixed Obamacare
or repeal Obamacare and those are the
two choices you can either try to fix
Obamacare by strengthening a lot of its
repercussions by subsidizing insurance
companies by creating by creating higher
taxes on it because the money has to
come from somewhere is what Democrats
would presumably like to do or move to
single-payer or you can get rid of
Obamacare entirely which is what
Republicans we're willing to do instead
they sort of settled for the worst of
both worlds
keep the regulations get rid of the
funding
which destroys the insurance companies
and forces Republicans to bail out the
insurance company she's a crappy bill so
here is the process of thought
Republicans wanted to pass something
more comprehensive that was rejected on
Wednesday then they said okay well how
about if we just do repeal only which
would be a broader version of repeal
that would still leave the regulations
in place that ones down to flaming tepee
and finally he said we'll do skinnier
repeal but we in the Senate don't
actually want to pass skinnier repeal
we'd like to have some subsidies in
there but we can't pass that through our
Senate right now so we want to do is
pass kinney repeal and make Paul Ryan
say that he won't pass Kenny repeal in
the house and then we'll go to
conference committee will come up with a
bill that we can all agree on and then
we'll revote it and Paul Ryan was not
giving a lot of signs that he was going
to do that he's sort of kind of
committed to the idea that they were
going to go to to a committee that was
going to put together a conference
committee that was going to put together
a new bill but in the end the bill goes
down to flaming defeat after John McCain
Susan Collins and Lisa Murkowski decide
they're not going to vote for it Collins
and Rakowski were never going to vote
for it because the internet should
believe in repealing Obamacare McCain
didn't vote for it presumably because
McCain was angry at the process so as we
played his speech a couple of days ago
he basically said I don't like how this
is being done I'm going to vote on a
motion to proceed but I'm not going to
vote on any bill and he fulfilled that
promise to the Democrats that that's who
John McCain is that is no great shock
however I think a lot of the sort of
freaked out is over the top I think a
lot of the freaked out is is over the 10
now listen Ted Cruz is right in 2012
when there was the government shutdown
and Ted Cruz said listen if we don't
defund Obamacare right this instant it
is going to be ensconced in American
life it is going to be enshrined in
American lives can be very difficult to
get rid of it he was exactly right when
he said that that has obviously been
proved to be true the Republican Party
has been lying for seven years they
actually wanted to get rid of this thing
they clearly do not want to get rid of
this thing Cruz last night he said
listen no party can remain in power by
lying to the American people and then
not fulfilling promises there's no issue
I have fought harder on devoted more
time too
than stopping the disaster that is
Obamacare and mark my words I am
committed to this fight as long as there
is breath in my body
I will be fighting for the working men
and women of this country that are being
hurt by Obamacare and I believe it will
would be repealed no party can remain in
power by lying to the American people
and I hope and pray that our party
doesn't try to do this okay and that is
what the party is going to try to do
they were lying for a long time however
the political costs here are not quite
as clear-cut as the Democrats are trying
to make it to the Democrats are saying
big victory for us big win for us not
quite so it's in watts for a Mitch
McConnell who was supposed to be able to
get his caucus together do something and
he couldn't right so it's a lost fervor
for senator turtle it is a loss for
Donald Trump who unfortunately his
late-game push for health care namely
saying that his attorney general was a
poophead did not actually have the
impact that people thought it was his
closing argument that his attorney
general was was garbage that actually
didn't believe it or not push this bill
over the finish line so tweeting out a
couple of times we can do a tea which is
basically what he tweeted out like two
minutes before this vote and then it
failed that isn't going to do it because
unfortunately the way the system works
you know it's not Trump's fault
completely but Trump has to be the
spearhead yes to be the guy who builds
up the who builds up the credibility in
the bill he's got to be the guy who
creates public pressure this is what
Obama's did on a regular basis Obama was
good at this Trump is not and so it is
Trump's fault a little bit but here is
the truth if Republicans had passed the
skinny repeal bill and if that had gone
to Trump's Tuscon if you'd signed it
they would have had a momentary
celebration and then the premiums would
have started rising dramatically it had
been very difficult to get Republicans
to vote for subsidies to bail out all
the insurance companies if they did they
would then own the subsidy regime and as
the insurance premiums continued to rise
and they were now sponsoring subsidies
there'd be a call for single-payer from
the left and Republicans would own this
thing right now it's unclear who owns
this thing right Democrats made it all
the failures our Democrats fault our
voters going to blame Republicans for
not fixing it are they going to blame
Democrats for creating it that's not
actually that's not actually clear also
when you push a bill that was proposed
at lunch time and you vote on it by
midnight that's not going to make
anybody happy
process doesn't matter very much when
there's a widespread perception that the
process has been corrupt that does
matter
I mean we should have learned this from
the Democrats in 2010 the Democrats
rammed through Obamacare through a
crappy process they hid the text of the
bill Nancy Pelosi said we'll only know
how it works basically once it's
implemented and the effect of that was
that they lost a thousand seats across
the country they lost the house they
lost the Senate and they lost the White
House so we have a good a good history
of what happens when you pass an
unpopular bill through inauspicious
means an unsavory means it's not good so
to a certain extent there's a good
possibility that John McCain and Susan
Collins and Lisa Murkowski actually
saved the Republicans from themselves on
this thing better to pass no bill in
some cases then it has a crappy build it
gives you ownership of the entire system
so I'm not completely you know you know
how cynical I am about politics I'm not
completely sold on the idea that this is
a killer for Republicans if they don't
pass anything and I think the Trump is
not entirely wrong when he says if this
thing continues to fall apart people are
going to look for a fix and they're not
going to look to they may not look to
Democrats who built the thing in the
first place so with all of that
happening it would have been helpful if
Trump actually wanted to push something
through which apparently he did if you
wanted to push something through it
would have been helpful if you weren't
distracted by stupidity it would be
helpful if you want to fight back on the
Russia thing if you weren't distracted
by stupidity unfortunately he's deeply
distracted by the stupidity inside his
own administration it has basically
become Game of Thrones and it's really
quite hilarious
it's like Game of Thrones but if we're
with Muppets that's sort of what's
happening here so in just a second I'll
give you the scare Moochie update but
before I do that I first want to say
thank you to our sponsors over the u.s.
concealed-carry Association so us CCA is
one of the finest organizations in
America they help educate you about how
to use a gun they help you obtain a gun
because they now have a drawing that
they are doing it defend my family now
too I turn me a 5 big chances to win
1776 dollars worth of guns and ammo the
most important thing they do over at the
UFC CA is that make sure you are legally
and financially protected for after you
pull the trigger they give you the
education and the training but then what
happens after you have to shoot at
somebody or shoot somebody the police
come the next three years of your life
are wrapped up in court this is what USC
CA is for they're there to protect you
in case of legal proceeding based on you
having to use a gun in self-defense just
a group that is vital for all gun owners
you should be you should have membership
with you
see see a you never want to be put in
the position where you're unprepared and
you sec and make sure that you are
prepared for before during and after a
shoot so defendant is my family now calm
is the place where you can get five
chances to win 1776 dollars worth of
guns and ammo it's not going to last
much longer this drawing so five big
chests went again defend my family now
calm right now and you should you should
get a membership with the u.s. ECA
anyway one of the best gun organizations
in the country okay so I hesitated to
share this with you until later in the
show because it is so glorious that I'm
going to lose my I'm going to lose my
mind it's so fantastic so we have now
initiated the scarer Moochie update for
as long as is in the white house so it
is time for the scary Moochie update
let's play his theme song excellent okay
so time for the scaramouche update so it
all begins yesterday morning we go back
in our time-travel machine okay we're
back in time yesterday morning Anthony
scaramouche II sees that Ryan Lizza
who's reported that he called Wednesday
night Ryan was is reporting about what
Skinner moshe has said to him or a
threatened leakers and he's going to
fire everybody etc etc and here in which
he calls into CNN and he starts off the
conversation by saying I never meant to
threaten Reince Priebus I never meant to
suggest that Reince Priebus is the
leaker within 30 seconds he's explaining
that Ryan's previous is probably the
leaker and should defend himself you
guys know who the leakers are I respect
him for not telling me because I
understand and respect journalistic
integrity however when I put out a tweet
I quote writes his name in the tweet
they're all making the assumption that
it's him because journalists know who
the leakers are so if lines wants to
explain that he's not a leaker let him
do that
if Brent's wants to explain he's not a
leaker let him do that yeah that's that
said it's a real strong repudiation of
the idea that you don't think he's
believing he's the leaker Anthony
Skinner Moshe this dude can do the
fandango like nobody's business then he
says it means declared war inside the
administration against all of these
people right he's declared war again in
the administration against Reince and
against ban basically anyone who wants
to do conservative policy is on Anthony
poopless because Anthony Skinner Moochie
wants to me Trump's right-hand man and
he has somehow parlayed being on
national television saying nice things
about Trump and ripping CNN into
becoming probably the second most
powerful man in the country which is
incredible it's such a great scam in any
case here he is going after other
members of the administration again
remember this is on CNN he called in to
do this he's like he is Trump's mini-me
I mean it's like Trump went out and had
a mini-me crafted just like Austin
Powers and now Trump is sitting there
and scared when she's performing for him
this is what this is right he's
performing for Trump and amazing here we
go last night we're having dinner
I told his wife I looked over to the
first lady and I said I forgot how much
fun I used to have and I hung out with
him on the campaign trail okay he's a
very interesting and very unique guy
there are people inside the
administration that think it is their
job to save America from this president
okay that is not their job their job is
to inject this president into America
and so that he can explain his views
properly and his policies so that we can
transform America and drain the swamp
and make the system fairer for the
middle and lower income people
I understand that you understand that we
have to inject Trump like Botox into the
buttocks of America it is that's that's
what has to happen here we can't contain
him in any way we can't ask him to put a
policy in any way we need more Trump let
Trump be Trump and then this is always
going to happen I thought it's gonna be
banded by the way who pushed this line
because Bannon is a sycophant to power
but it turns out that Steve Bannon at
long last has some principles it
actually wants to promote those
principles in power I mean this is weird
for me because I really do not like
Steve Anand personally but Bannon is one
of the people who is now on the poop
list for Anthony Skinner Moochie and
then he decides that it's important for
him to go after Ryan even more he says
that we're like brothers maybe we're
like Cain and Abel maybe we're not we
don't know if you want to talk about the
staff we have had ODS we have had
differences when I said we were brothers
from the on the podium that's because
we're rough up some brothers are like
Cain and Abel other brothers can fight
with each other and then get along I
don't know if this is repairable or not
that will be up to the president but you
could chief of staff he's responsible
this administration is so high Cain
murdered Abel
because of your ear on national TV
suggesting that you might be like Cain
and Abel you might also just be like
brothers who fight a little bit and then
get along but I might murder him and
bury him in the backyard I mean
basically Sierra Moochie is Joe Pesci
from casino it's incredible I love it
and then Sarah Huckabee Sanders is out
there and it's pretty clear this is now
scaramouche's administration so far as
Trump is concerned Huckabee Sanders is
out there saying that she won't commit
to saying whether Trump supports his own
chief of staff remember this is in the
same week that Trump has been tweeting
out about how his own AG's a poophead
you can't say right now the president
has full confidence and she just
outlined scream I think it's answered
that I look I think what we have this is
a White House that has a lot of
different perspectives because the
president hires the very best people
they're not always going to agree
they're going to be a lot of different
ideas unlike the previous
administrations this isn't groupthink
it's not groupthink it's not something
if you don't kiss from jasmine enough
then he starts yelling at you on Twitter
at one point yesterday scare mode she
says he doesn't hire yes men literally
scare emojis only job is to say yes to
Trump that is his only job it's amazing
okay so that's not even a good talk guys
I didn't get to the good part yet for
the good part you're going to have to go
over to Daley wire yeah I know right
great case there the best part you're
going to have to go over to Daley wire
and subscribe for nine nine in a month
you too can be part of the process and
you can hear the good stuff because it
is like HBO I'm going to go blue in just
a second here because it's amazing
so for $9.99 a month you can watch the
rest of the show live it is not just an
audio show does a video show you can see
all of the amazing that's happened in
real time you get Mitro lodging at
Andrew Clavin show live
you get michael Knowles's new show which
premieres on monday god help us a
subtitle to show this is my thought
about the show god help us lives you can
get that as well you can part of the
mailbag which we'll be doing will be
taking live questions in the mailbag as
well so very exciting stuff you can
check all that out of daily wire.com or
get an annual subscription for $99 so it
does count plus you get this incredible
magnificent incomparable phenomenal
unbelievable paper this mug this leftist
here is hot or cold tumbler it is the
greatest thing you will ever own in your
life you may own a house you may own a
horse you may own a car but this in a
fire this is the only thing I'm going to
be able to grab and take with you family
photos
forget them it's that tumblr that you're
going to want to take leftist here's hot
or cold tumblr and you get that with the
annual subscription so go over and check
that out at daily we're calm or if you
just want to listen to the show later go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud and give us
a listen we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
United States
okay so now the good stuff so last night
after scare emoji goes on CNN and things
seem to have calmed down a little bit
because now we're all going to focus on
the health care stuff and now we're all
going to focus on on what Trump is doing
about sessions and rather than focus on
some of the rush of stuff and like what
we'll go about our daily business no we
won't
because the magic happened Ryan Lizza
releases a piece about the about what
scared when she had set him on Wednesday
night
scaramouche he'd apparently does not
know this is what scaramouche basically
says he does not know the difference
between on the record and off the record
so for those who don't understand how
this works
okay on the when you're speaking with a
journalist and you're a source for a
journalist the person who you are
speaking to the journalist has to agree
that something is off the record in
order for it to be off the record so if
I'm on the phone with the journalist and
I say hey this is off the record and the
guy doesn't agree it's not off the
record it's all in honor system
essentially because the journalists
don't want to burn sources because then
they can never use the sources again so
off the record means what I'm saying to
you can never be printed in any
circumstances on background means that
you can print it but you're going to
quote me as say you know a unnamed daily
wire employee right that that would be
on background and then finally there is
on the record which is you can quote me
as a since anybody who has done one iota
of media knows va's anthony scaramouche
is the head of White House
communications and he did not know this
at least that's his excuse then he said
no it's kind of on purpose that I did
this okay so why does that matter
because he didn't interview Ryan Lizza
and I'm going to tell you about this
interview so he started off by
threatening to fire everyone on the
White House communication staff he said
which said first of all every time I see
him all I am reminded I mean it's he's
like a cross between he's like some
perverse cross between Christian Bale
from American Psycho Leonardo DiCaprio
from the wolf of Wall Street and Ellis
from the and Ellis from from die hard
you know Huns boogie I'm your white
knight that guy so anyway the mooch I
wanted so I loved it so like patent I
love itself
did I ask these guys not to leak
anything and they can't help themselves
you're an American said it's any talking
to reporter now you're an American
citizen this is a major catastrophe for
the and for the American country so I'm
asking you
American patriot to give me a sense of
who we did so he's asking the reporter
now to tell him who the leakers are
which is not what reporters do and then
when Lisbeth said no that much that okay
I'm gonna fire every one of them and
then you haven't protected anybody so
the entire place will be fired over the
next two weeks okay this is like the
stupidest threat ever
it's like he's basically saying if you
don't do this I'm going to punch myself
directly in the nuts that's what I'm
going to do I'm gonna fire everyone
around me and then we'll see how you
like it
Hey look okay go go ahead and be like
all right I suppose you could do that
yeah but it gets better he says they'll
all be fired by me I fired one guy the
other day I have three to four people
I'll fire tomorrow I'll get to the
reason who week tat to you
Reince Priebus do you want to leave
something he'll be asked to resign very
shortly and this is all on the record
guys is on the record meaning he wanted
it to be printed rhymes is an effing
paranoid schizophrenic a paranoiac and
then imitating Ryan says voice he goes
hope he'll shine is coming in let me
meet the effing thing and see if I can
bleep block these people the way I bleep
blocked scaramouche II for six months
this is all on the record okay so he's
ripping chief of staff for the President
of the United States at the White House
and he's saying that he clocked blocked
him I mean that's insane
and it gets better yes so then Skinner
Moochie was very upset because there was
a release of his public disclosure forms
he was working at the Export Import Bank
and you have to fill out all these forms
those are public record after a certain
period of time so those were released
this week he thought that Ryan Phillippe
them to the media and accused Rhines of
committing a felony he said quote I've
called the FBI and the Department of
Justice the swamp will not defeat him
they're trying to resist me but it's not
going to work I've done nothing wrong on
my financial disclosures so they're
going to have to go after themselves and
then it got even better so good it's
like late it's like inception layers of
Awesome scaramouche II he finishes by
saying this I'm not Steve Annan I'm not
trying to suck my own clock seven
o'clock he said I'm not trying to build
my own brand off the effing strength of
the president I'm here to serve the
country so now he's attacking the White
House chief strategist as a guy who is
in love with the media and wants to be
in front of the cameras and also wants
to perform anatomically impossible acts
on himself
I know Steve Annan he's not that
physically flexible there's just no way
there's just no way I could say other
things about this but I'm going to leave
it at that
the so he is now accused the White House
chief of staff and being a paranoid
schizophrenic and she D been accused
abandon the White House strategists of
trying to suck his own thing and and
then he continued what I want to do is
effing kill all the leakers and I want
the President's agenda on track so we
can succeed for the American people
okay the mood showed up a week ago this
is going to get cleaned up very shortly
okay because I nailed these guys I've
got digital fingerprints and everything
they've done for the FBI in the effing
Department of Justice well the felony
they're going to get prosecuted probably
for the felony which felony nobody knows
also how did he get ahold of the FBI and
DOJ records why does he have
fingerprints no one knows so all of this
is going swimmingly and then he says you
know what let me go I got to start
tweeting some bleep to make this guy
crazy a minute later he sent that tweet
directed at Reince Priebus in which he
accused private previously being weaker
and then the next morning he went on CNN
and said that's not what I meant by that
weight shot unreal so good so here's a
question for everyone I'm wildly
entertained okay if I had my druthers
right now the only person in the
administration I care about maintaining
is is the Anthony's camera mode tree
like this I don't care if they fire
everyone I don't care if they fire pens
like all I want from life right now is
Anthony Skinner Moochie in front of the
camera every minute of every day
I don't think Trump feels the same way
the reason is because Trump wants to be
in front of the camera every minute of
every day which is why CBN and did the
clever thing of going to his old friend
to Breitbart went to Tony Lee who's is a
reporter very friendly to Trump
I mean aunt abandon who was very
friendly when Brandon was there and Tony
Lee ran a long piece at house care
Moochie was stealing the spotlight from
Trump which is of course the smartest
way to appeal to Trump is to say someone
is stealing your spotlight and from
close
no no Enfield's my spotlight hit him
with a hammer and bury him in the desert
so that's that's Bannon steak so the
boat front it's great squirming she's
trying to accuse ban and of trying to
steal the spotlight and bandhans trying
to accuse Skinner Moochie of stealing
the spotlight all in a battle to try and
be second-in-command
Trump but scaramouche she has no
principles and doesn't care about what
Trump pushes and Bannon has some
principles but some of them suck so all
of it is just going awesome as I think
the short story here also Jeff Sessions
who's the Attorney General he just got
to be relieved that now he's out of the
spotlight because earlier this week
ultram cared about
ripping on jeff sessions jeff sessions
was talking to tucker carlson and he
said Trump's tweets have been very
hurtful this week you've seen the
president's criticism of you do you
think it's fair well it's kind of
hurtful but the president of united
states is a strong leader he is
determined to move this country in the
direction he believes it needs to go to
make us great again and he is had a lot
of criticisms and he's steadfastly
determined to get his job done and he
wants all of us to do our jobs and
that's what I intend to do the president
that sort of the latest so even if
sessions is trying to be a loyal soldier
here and saying it's kind of hurtful
it's basically turned into a dating show
will trump in sessions makeup will
scaramouche e'en rinds get into a crying
management is basically this is reality
Housewives of Washington DC it's
incredible and one of these people could
end up replacing Melania I mean you just
don't know it's it's why we entered him
now
so then forward any policy of course not
it doesn't do anything to forward policy
okay we haven't had any policy except
for Gorsuch in like six months
but at least this part of its ramping up
at least this part is entertaining so if
what you're starting to see is that it
undermines Trump's entire agenda because
Trump in personnel is policy and he's
not selected the best people and not
only has he not selected the best people
he's treated his own employees like the
Joker treats people in the Dark Knight
he's basically said I'm hiring here's a
pool cue there's one pool cue into you
one of you comes out alive and gets
hired this is not the way to run an
administration then this is why you're
seeing senator is beginning to buck
Trump Ben Sasse is it has openly said
now that if Trump is going to fire
sessions and then try to make a recess
appointment of a new Attorney General
that we're going to stop him in the
Senate in 2014 the US Supreme Court
ruled that the Obama administration had
made unconstitutional appointments when
it declared this body to be in recess
when the US Senate was not in fact in
recess and it functionally claimed power
that is the administration functionally
claims power that belonged to the Senate
under our Constitution
so today I've come to the floor to keep
my promise and to offer a word of humble
advice to the president
if you're thinking of making a recess
appointment to push out the Attorney
General forget about it the presidency
isn't a bowl and this country isn't a
china shop okay so even the senators are
starting to buck in Lindsey Graham came
out and he said that any effort to go
after the special council would would
basically finish Trump you know the
senators are beginning to be fed up with
this and they're not getting any policy
so you know I hope that everybody is
enjoying the reality show I hope they
are but this is an F week for Trump okay
great um every week the last two weeks
have been apps he needs to do better
than this get back on your policy horse
shut up on Twitter stop attacking your
own employees if you don't like sessions
get rid of him
if you don't like rides get rid of him
be a man man up clean up your
administration okay you know I keep
hearing the terms of Nasser businessman
okay I run a business if somebody here
is bad at their job but we fired them
that's how it works if you don't do your
job you get laid off and then you get
somebody else who replaces you who
presumably does a better job and then if
the business fails that's my fault
because I'm the head of the business
okay that's the same thing at the head
of the government the executive branch
is an executive branch that are supposed
to execute are you seeing anything
executed except some random staffers I
mean at this point Sean Spicer is just
sitting around basically in Sean Spicer
sitting around on a beach in Zihuatanejo
sipping a beer and going thank God I
escaped he crawled through 300 yards of
foul-smelling not can't even imagine and
came out clean on the other side Sean
Spicer I mean it's just that that's
what's become now you know good days how
about some good things okay so now I
want to I want to take a moment and talk
about what happened in Washington DC
yesterday so I had the privilege of
speaking before the Government Oversight
Committee Subcommittee on the
Subcommittee on education is led by
representative Jim Jordan from fourth
District of Ohio a bunch people stopped
by Dave brat stop by from Virginia and
and representative De Santis stop by
from Florida Eleanor Holmes Norton
stopped by from District of Columbia and
there are a couple of moments that I
thought was worthwhile so here was my
opening statement you don't play the
whole thing we'll play a little bit of
it and just a Easter Egg that is a
god-king of The Daily wire and Jeremy
boring sitting behind me to my right
wearing the three-piece suit looking
glorious of course here is some my
opening statement
justifying before you here today the
reason that I'm with you is that I speak
on dozens of college campuses every year
so I have some first-hand experience
with the anti First Amendment activities
that have been taking places on the
college campuses I've encountered
anti-free speech measures administrative
cowardice even physical violence at
campuses ranging from California State
University of Los Angeles to University
of Wisconsin at Madison which is driving
the legislation that Miss Demings is
talking about at the Penn State
University to UC Berkeley and I am NOT
alone in order to understand what's been
going on at some of our college campuses
it's necessary to explore the ideology
that provides the impetus for a lot of
the protesters who violently obstruct
events call fire alarms and solve
professor's and even other students and
the impetus for administrators who all
too often humor these protesters free
speech is under assault because of a
three-step argument made by the
advocates and justify errs of violence
the first step is they say that the
validity or invalidity of an argument
can be judged solely by the ethnic
sexual racial or cultural identity of
the person making the argument the
second step is that they claim those who
say otherwise are engaging with what
they call verbal violence and the final
step is they conclude that physical
violence is sometimes justified in order
to stop such verbal violence okay so I
went on from there but I slapped out an
intersectionality I said that
intersectionality was the root of the
modern Democratic Party which set off
some of the congresspeople I thought the
best exchange was there was a
representative named Plaskett
who's actually from the Virgin Islands
she's not technically a congresswoman
she's a representative who sits with
Congress and she came after me because
she was she was upset that I had said
that the arguments about white privilege
on campus are a way to shut down debate
and provide impetus for a lot of the
protesters who simply think that nobody
else should be able to speak her words
are exchanged I had a conversation with
Rachel Lazar who's done some work a
Jewish American woman who's done some
work on this area as well as having
extensive conversations with dr. Greg
parks of Wake Forest University who's
also talked quite a bit about critical
race theory and it's my understanding
that white privilege is not telling
individuals that they cannot
but it is a term for societal privilege
that individuals have as a benefit of
their white skin and I don't think that
and I think universities would be remiss
to then say that because you're white
you're not allowed to say anything
that's critical of white people I didn't
know that white privilege actually went
into that sphere my understanding is
it's just and the issue is is that white
privilege makes people uncomfortable to
talk about the societal privilege that
they have well it to me the what I found
campuses all the time is if you're one
of cite instances of racism that we can
all find and fight together that's
something that I am more than willing to
stand next to you and fight because
that's obviously stuff that we should
fight together but when you just say
that there is no white privilege out
there in the ether and that by dint of
birth your skin color generates for you
an advantage what you are really saying
to people is that you your view is
what's valuable because you have not
experienced what I've experienced and
that is an identity argument that's the
character argument that's not a rational
political argument that can actually be
taken on in any way that's it's more of
as more of a cudgel and a club than it
is an attempt to open the discussion ok
so you can see it got a little bit
heated from time to time in the in the
hearing it was really worthwhile because
I want to get see things I like things I
hit in the mailbag we'll cut it short
there but it was it's worthwhile you
should go and watch I think somebody put
together a compilation of all the
sections where I'm talking if that's the
part you want to watch a lot of the
other people who are speaking had
interesting things to say but really
fascinating hearing and it's kind of a
kick I mean thanks to all of the kids
who came there there were a bunch of
college students who showed up filled
the audience we felt like a movie we're
walking through the hallways and
everybody was cheering is pretty was
pretty hilarious I wanted to have Jeremy
behind me start a slow clap after I
finished stuff but we didn't actually do
that I was also deeply tempted to just
open my testimony by saying it's me I'm
the leaker just to see what would happen
but I did not in fact do that okay time
for some things I like and then some
things I hate mailbag so we will do only
one thing I like to take time to get the
mailbag the thing that I like we've been
doing all week music that you've heard
from movies this one is really overused
but it is of course super famous this is
Rachmaninoff spare it's a
I on a theme of Paganini it's the the
Rhapsody thank you on a theme of
Paganini this is the orchestral version
it's been used in a number of films
[Music]
beautiful music obviously used in movies
ranging from dead again which is a
little-known Kenneth Branagh film -
somewhere in time which is the most
famous uses the question for Eve and I
what's her name I can never remember the
name of the Jane Seymour mystery anymore
which is a take-off on movie time and
again which is a better book than it is
a movie apparently was used recently it
was using Groundhog Day also they use it
briefly in Groundhog Day because Bill
Murray wants to play the piano and then
he uses this to to woo women but it's it
is a great piece of music on and off is
great in short sections I'm not sure I
like Rachmaninoff that much overall but
this is the best of his the best of
Rachmaninoff okay now the other thing
that I like I lied there would be one
more thing I like a representative to
Sanchez who's just a hilarious fellow
from Florida he's a big fan of the show
and his wife is a sweetheart and he had
me FaceTime with her a little bit
beforehand he actually asked me that Ben
Shapiro thug life is now part of the
Congressional Record this is the thing
that happened Ben Shapiro who came up
with the thug life Ben Shapiro I have no
idea on what may I have never listened
to a complete rap song in my entire life
mmm it's funny and it's well done it has
some of your greatest hits I mean dude
so I'm sure Doug's life guy guy he gets
a pat on the back for all that whoever
you are well done
I can't believe in retrospect I really
missed the opportunity to say the thug
life chose me and put that in the
Congressional Record that would have
been so epic and now I'm really pissed
at myself okay so okay so um time for
thing that I hate
so the thing that I hate today is I hate
when the left pretends that Trump is
doing something that he's not so
president Trump's DOJ has told
businesses that they that the the Civil
Rights Act does not cover sexual
orientation that's because the Civil
orientation laws mean things okay they
mean the things that they said when they
were written and the Civil Rights Act
does not cover discrimination on the
basis of sexual orientation there's a
headline that says from media Trump's
DOJ tells businesses it's now totally
cool to discriminate against LGBT no
that's not what Trump's DOJ says from
CEO J says there is no legislation on
the books on the federal level that
prevents discrimination on the basis of
sexual orientation which is true hey the
law is still the meaning of the law and
this is how the Left likes to twist
things but they do is they like to take
the most egregious misuses of freedom
and they say well you're for that
therefore we should quash the freedom
and that's really disgusting race use of
free speech all the time they say well
freeze to be on campus with a lot to say
well free speech that means that you're
in favor of people saying the n-word
aren't you they know I'm in favor of the
right for people to say the n-word but I
think saying the n-word is a terrible
thing I think the discrimination on the
basis of sexual orientation is a bad
thing unless you're talking about in a
religious context or in some context or
it might be values laden and relevant
but if you're to but this idea that the
federal government has a role to play in
jumping on this number one I think is
anti freedom and number two is I think
not a I don't think the government at
all should be involved in issues of this
order but it is certainly not covered by
the Civil Rights Act you don't just get
to rewrite law because you wish that the
law said something that it doesn't say
so that that needs to stop okay so let's
jump right into the mailbag we have a
little bit of time for the mail
excellence so andrew says dear Ben you
seem like a ladies man how can I use my
conservative beliefs to attract women so
I start off with like discussion on
religious liberty or going confident
with my line-by-line analysis of
Declaration of Independence so far
neither method has been successful
Andrew so I am NOT in fact a ladies man
I know I'm highly attracted to women but
I was the first long-term girlfriend
that I had I married so that's so I was
not I was not only that and I think a
lot of that had to do with the fact
that not only am i an abrasive human
being from time to time but also I think
that I was a couple years younger than
everyone else wherever I went ever so
there was that um listen I am NOT into
the ladies man lifestyle also that
really is the real answer I'm not into
the sleeping around I'm not into the no
I don't think men should do this I don't
think that being a ladies man is a
worthwhile goal I think you should try
to find the person who's going to make
you a better human being and you should
and you should create a family with that
human being and create children with
that human being and that means that you
should leave with values on my first
date I've said this before my first date
with my wife we talked about freewill
versus determinism this is a
legitimately this is a three our first
date on which we talk about freewill and
determinant and telling my wife was was
deeply into philosophy it was just that
we were talking about religion very well
and all this stuff and that's because
values matter values matter when you're
trying to determine with whom you should
partner in life okay Robert says okay
but I know you aren't against birth
control this is true as an Orthodox Jew
what is your opinion on sterilization
like tubal litigation and vasectomies so
I am not in favor of irreversible
surgeries that prevent you from having
children I am did you know I'm going to
separate my own religious viewpoint here
because you know I'm not going to speak
for Orthodox Judaism you can ask a rabbi
if you want the Orthodox Jewish
perspective on these things I don't like
the idea of sterilizing yourself unless
you are attempting to you know unless
here if you if you really really don't
want to have kids which I think has a
moral component to it if you really
don't want to have kids and you need to
be a better person if you don't want to
have children but if you if you really
really don't want to have kids then you
know I don't have a problem with you
doing what you want to do it's a free
country on a moral level I think that
taking permanent steps to cure a
transitory issue is not the smartest
thing to do
matt says - do you believe there's a
secular case for the natural rights of
life liberty and property I think there
is a secular case in the sense that you
don't have to mention the Bible or God
no but I do think that eventually you're
going to have to fall into a
judeo-christian history that's a little
bit vague and this is the problem with
natural rights theory as a general as a
general theory it's all well and good to
say that it is self-evident that there
are natural rights but it is clearly not
self-evident that they're natural right
that Springs from a particularly a
Christian ideology that goes back to the
foundations of Christianity and Greek
thought and Judaism and to pretend that
you can just sit there in a room and
come up with life liberty and property
as the as the fundamental principles I
think that's a little bit this guided
there there's a reason that not every
society on planet Earth in fact most
societies for the majority of history
did not believe that life liberty and
property were inherent rights it
required a judeo-christian civilization
developing toward an Enlightenment
freedom to believe that ok rachel says
payment this week in my sociology class
at Brooklyn College we mentioned the
idea of being woke and there was a
debate about whether awareness is enough
to help invoke change first of all I
hate the phrase being woke because it
suggests that everybody else is asleep
and also it's improper grammar okay it's
being awakened
you're not woke idiots and some argue
that awareness of the situation was
irrelevant if action was not taken what
is your stance and how do you find the
idea of being woke so listen I think
that you should be aware of as many
things going around you as possible
being woke again is I think a moral
judgment that people use if you don't
agree with them they said you're not
woke maybe I'm aware of your argument I
think it blows that's a possibility but
that's never that's never taken into
account when you say that I'm not woke
all right being woke is basically say
you're not part of the club man you're
not cool like I give a crap okay in says
what in your opinion is the single
greatest quality a person can have
humility which is why I'm so damn humble
but it but I actually think the single
greatest quality a person can have like
the president naturally I believe in
loyalty but I don't believe in loyalty
to two humans I believe in loyalty to
God and to values I think you're loyal
to those things then it's hard to go
wrong now Jackson says Haven do you
believe people that come into this
legally and don't see into the country
legally agem and don't speak English
should be given a choice to attend free
classes to learn English I mean I don't
believe in free anything I believe that
if you come here at your obligation to
learn English and that's on you that's
an affirmative obligation on you now I
think that Israel makes a smart move if
you want people to assimilate there's a
case to be made that you should attempt
to facilitate that but I'm not sure that
that is I'm not sure that you should
have to pay for okay final question -
Ramona's question with all the news that
is almost really good these days how do
you manage to stay happy and in a good
mood I finally the news especially
involving Trump in the GOP supposed to
be on my side really turning me off what
do you do to keep yourself sane
well I go home and I
right this is the beauty of the shabath
I was talking with God came a daily
wired Jeremy boring just yesterday about
this that one if I have to turn off my
phone from Friday night to Saturday
night and not turn on my computer from
Friday night to Saturday night and then
on Sundays I spend the time with my
children and I don't do politics you
need that break because it returns you
to what is truly valuable it also
reminds what you're fighting for which
is a social fabric that is worth
upholding and a freedom from government
intrusion that is worth that is worth
fighting and the freedom is worth
upholding obviously so I think you need
to take breaks you need to take breaks
being ensconce in politics there's a
tweet that came out today from this
idiot Democrat Chris Murphy where he
said last night proved once again
there's no anxiety or sadness or fury
you feel right now that cannot be cured
by political action only a fascist does
crap like that
okay anxiety fear or sadness can only be
cured not by political action in
changing the world but by you creating a
a safe place for yourself surrounded by
people that you love and who you want to
protect and that also gives you a
rationale for fighting in the first
place
okay we move at your next week with more
entertainment more wildness more joy
Sunday if you're if you're out in
California make sure that you come out
to poetic on I am debating shank Eiger I
think that's how his name is pronounced
I know it's person named Frank Wright oh
the Young Turks dude it should be
entertaining and informative or least I
hope it is and so if you come out on
Sunday you can come and watch that I'd
be glad to meet you and see you over
politican on Sunday and we will be
rehashing all of that come Monday
morning so wats to get to already by
Monday we'll talk about all of it I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]